[Musica]
[Applauso]
quanti di voi si sono sentiti rivolgere
almeno una volta nella vita
questa domanda e tu che cosa vuoi fare
da grande
io penso tutti è una domanda che di
solito si fa ai bambini quando siamo
curiosi di sapere cosa l'influenza e si
fa le persone un po più grandi per
capire quali sono i loro piani per il
futuro
quasi sempre io faccio questa domanda
anche ai miei studenti al termine del
loro percorso universitario in quella
fase in cui loro devono tenere a mente
tutto quello che hanno imparato fino a
quel momento e devono prepararsi alla
vita professionale
da qualche anno a questa parte diciamo
almeno cinque o sei
la risposta che mi sento dare più spesso
è non lo so dipende dipende da chi mi
offrirà lavoro dopo
dipende se riuscirò a trovare i soldi
per fare un master
dipende se potrò permettermi di fare uno
stage non retribuito dipende
e se anche tu li incalzi cercando di
chiedere ma se dipendesse solo da te se
non ci fosse nessun vincolo esterno a
fermarti che cosa vorresti fare le loro
dicono fa che non ci avevo mai pensato
ovviamente sto generalizzando ma vi
posso assicurare che sono grandi numeri
è come se quella domanda che quando
eravamo bambini ci faceva fantasticare
si fosse improvvisamente trasformata in
una spina nel fianco nei confronti di
questi giovani che sembrano nei
confronti del futuro così sfiduciati e
così io spesso mi sono chiesta che cosa
fosse successo in questi 20 anni che
sono circa gli anni che separano la mia
giovinezza della loro di così importante
ed aver cambiato così radicalmente
questa prospettiva è così torno con la
mente a pensare a come io alla loro età
immaginavo il futuro
io ho trascorso la mia infanzia degli
anni 80 e la mia adolescenza negli anni
90 facendo parte come si diceva prima
proprio di questa micro generazione
che sociologi definiscono ksenia perché
a metà tra queste due generazioni che
hanno vissuto il passaggio tra
l'analogico il digitale in una fase
molto delicata della loro vita io
infatti ho trascorso la mia infanzia e
la mia adolescenza quindi quelle fasi in
cui si è più turbolenti in cui si ha
voglia di sperimentare senza web senza
telefonino in un'epoca totalmente
analogico in cui nessuno di noi poteva
immaginare cosa sarebbe successo dopo
e invece ho vissuto in pieno la
rivoluzione digitale quando ero già più
grande quando ero giovane e adulta
quindi quando avevo gia le idee un po
più chiare su quello che volevo fare nel
futuro e quindi mi sono spesso chiesta
come spesso mi sono chiesta come gli
altri ragazzi della mia generazione come
immaginavamo il futuro allora e se torno
alla mente a quei giorni ricordo che
ovviamente il futuro era quello che ci
raccontavano il cinema la televisione e
quindi mi immaginavo un futuro fatto di
macchine volanti di space cowboy che
conquistavano l'universo e di nuove
tecnologie che avrebbero reso la nostra
vita meravigliosa in futuro vi siete mai
chiesti che cosa
trasmettiamo invece a questi bambini
adolescenti oggi quando il cinema la
televisione parlano loro di futuro
morti che tornano dall'aldilà donne
costrette alla schiavitù in un mondo
condannato alla sterilità epidemie
sterminatrici carestie nuove tecnologie
che in qualche maniera si sostituiscono
addirittura l'uomo facendolo vivere in
una specie di fake un futuro di grande
pessimismo e allora mi domando che cosa
sia successo che ciò abbia fatto passare
da un immaginario di guerre stellari e
la conquista dell'universo come il
nostro star wars ci insegnava ad invece
un immaginario così tremendo e cinico
come quello per esempio di the walking
dead
james berger che è un professore di yale
che è studia questi fenomeni dice che il
trionfo della distopia contemporanea la
distopia proprio questo nostro modo
catastrofico di vedere il futuro decreta
la sconfitta dell'immaginazione
quindi secondo questo studioso sarebbe
sufficiente tornare ad immaginare per
poter tornare ad essere ottimisti e
costruttivi nei confronti del futuro
ma come si fa intanto cominciando col
pensare che le immaginazioni di cui
parla berger è qualcosa di molto diverso
per esempio da quello che noi
immaginiamo essere fantasia perché per
quello ci basta sfogliare
penso che i giornali ogni giorno per
capire che di sicuro la fantasia non ci
manca solo qualche giorno fa leggevo che
solo in italia sarebbero più di 30.000
quindi molto più di tutti gli abitanti
di tolentino le persone che credono
veramente che la terra sia piatta e che
sia resta nei suoi confini da delle
altissime montagne di ghiaccio color
smeraldo alte 400 km lunghe 72 mila
chilometri sorvegliate da un esercito di
soldati provenienti da chissà dove
quando berger parla di immaginazione non
parla di questo parla di qualcosa di più
profondo di qualcosa che ha a che fare
con il nostro ragionare con il nostro
modo di concepire la conoscenza con il
nostro modo di relazionarci con il mondo
con qualcosa che ha che fare ancor prima
che con l'età e con le contingenze con
l'educazione e la cultura e io sono
onestamente d'accordo con questa
affermazione di berger e anzi vi dirò di
più io ho il giorno in cui ho cominciato
a capire che qualcosa dell'immaginazione
di questi giovani di questi ragazzi
stava cominciando a cambiare io me lo
ricordo molto bene
insegnavo già da qualche anno qui
all'università di macerata
andiamo semiotica non segnato sei minuti
cali per tanti anni ed era l'ultimo
giorno di lezione del mio corso ea pochi
minuti dalla fine della lezione mi
ricordo benissimo un ragazzo seduto in
prima fila con un maglioncino rosso alza
la mano e guardandomi dritto negli occhi
in maniera molto seria
mi dice senza professoressa io sono
venuto a tutte le sue lezioni
ho preso appunti ho studiato tutti i
testi che lei ci ha detto di studiare
quindi adesso glielo posso dire io non
ho capito a che cosa mi dovrebbero
servire tutti questi discorsi astratti
sul senso sul significato
quando poi uscirò da qui perché sa io
voglio trovare lavoro in azienda il
prima possibile e quindi vorrei capire a
che cosa mi dovrebbero servire tutte
quelle cose che lei ci ha detto poi
quando dovrò rispondere al mio datore di
lavoro nel giorno del mio primo
colloquio di lavoro
io a questo ragazzo
avrei dovuto rispondere quello che i
nostri professori al liceo ci
rispondevano quando noi chiedevamo loro
che cosa ci dovevano servire quelle
elezioni o traduzioni di latino e di
greco quando fuori dalla scuola dove
avremmo mai usate avrai ciò è dovuto
rispondere un giorno capirai un giorno
tutto quello che hai studiato qui che ha
imparato qui ti tornerà utile
improvvisamente capirai che avrei fatto
tesoro di qualcosa ma non potevo perché
questo ragazzo in realtà vi stava
chiedendo qualcos'altro
mi stava dicendo che lui le risposte non
le volevo un giorno lui con le risposte
le volevano in quel momento perché non
poteva aspettare un giorno per capire
perché lui doveva andare al suo
colloquio e dovrà rispondere al suo
datore di lavoro in quel momento
ma cosa c'entra questo con
l'immaginazione di cui parla berger
c'entra e per farvi capire in che modo
vorrei farvi un esempio molto semplice
che è l'esempio che
uno dei padri fondatori della semiotica
americana che charles anders perche
faceva nei suoi scritti per spiegare la
differenza che abbiamo per approcciarsi
al mondo dice perche immaginiamo di
entrare per la prima volta in una stanza
e di esplorarla quindi per la prima
volta la stanza è vuota al centro della
stanza c'è un tavolo e sopra al tavolo
c'è un sacco chiuso con un etichetta
bene attaccata in vista
l'etichetta dice fagioli bianchi dice
perche se io mi fido di quell etichetta
non dovrà investire molto tempo per
rispondere a chiunque fuori dalla stanza
mi dovesse chiedere scusa ma che c'era
nella stanza io potrei entrare uscire
dire c'è un sacco di fagioli bianchi mi
sarei fidato di una risposta che qualcun
altro aveva trovato per me ma dice perse
facciamo un altro esempio nella stanza
che noi esploriamo per la prima volta
troviamo sempre il nostro sacco chiuso
però questa volta il sacco non ha
etichetta
a questo punto per rispondere a chi ci
chiedesse che cosa c'è nella stanza e io
non potrei fidarmi di nulla
dovrei cercare di capire cosa c'è nel
sacco e quindi devo aprirlo e quindi
aprirò il mio sacco e comincerò a tirare
fuori il contenuto del sacco
vedrò che ci sono i fagioli bianchi
continuerò attirare cose fuori dal sacco
tirerò fuori ancora fagioli bianchi
alla fine un certo punto deciderò che è
sufficiente che ho tirato fuori
sufficienti elementi per poter capire
che forse nel sacco ci sono tutti i
fagioli bianchi e allora chiuderò il
sacco e ci metterò sopra la mia
etichetta e lo lascerò sul tavolo
chiaramente questa volta per rispondere
alla domanda io ho impiegato più tempo e
mi sono dovuto letteralmente sporcare le
mani per capire cosa ci fosse nel sacco
però questa volta la risposta la
risposta che io darò a chi è fuori dalla
stanza sarà un po più sicura per me
perché l'ho visto con i miei occhi che
cosa c'era nel sacco mi sentirò più
sicuro della mia risposta fin quando non
arriverà qualcun'altro dopo di me a
continuare diciamo rovistare nel sacco
scoprendo magari che oltre a fagioli
bianchi c'è qualcos'altro ma fino a quel
momento io sarò sicuro della mia
risposta ma dice perse facciamo ultima
ipotesi questa volta entriamo nella
nostra stanza in cui sul tavolo c'è il
nostro sacco con l'etichetta ben
attaccata sopra ma questa volta il sacco
è aperto e accanto al sacco troviamo una
manciata di fagioli bianchi
a questo punto se siamo curiosi
la domanda non è più che cosa c'è nel
sacco perché lo so che cosa c'è nel
sacco se mi fido dell'etichetta so che
ci sono fagioli bianchi la domanda sarà
come ci sono finiti come fagioli sul
tavolo che cosa è successo prima che
arrivassi io e quindi a quel punto
viceversa io inizio ad immaginare non a
fantasticare inizia ad immaginare inizio
a interrogare le cose della stanza alle
persone che c'erano prima di me mi
guarderò attorno per potermi creare un
ipotesi quindi farò una specie di
investigazione quindi farò delle domande
in giro e comincerò a ragionare forse
c'è stato qualcuno prima di me che ha
rovesciato il sacco o forse c'è un
animale in casa che ha rovinato il sacco
quando avrò diciamo accumulato
sufficienti elementi e mi sentirò sicuro
della mia idea allora a quel punto io
scommetterò sulla mia ipotesi
scommetto che c'è un animale in casa e
quindi agirò di conseguenza assumendomi
il rischio che quello che io penso non
sia vero
agirò di conseguenza posso perdere la
mia scommessa perché posso scoprire
andando in giro in cerca di un animale
che non c'è un animale in casa e quindi
a quel punto dovrò ricominciare da capo
ad immaginare dovrò di nuovo guardarmi
attorno dovrò di nuovo chiedere in giro
per cercarmi un'altra ipotesi come
potete capire rispetto agli altri due
esempi ho investito molto più tempo
adesso perché ho dovuto fare un'indagine
ho dovuto sforzarmi per avere
un'immagine ben precisa però volete
mettere la soddisfazione quando
scopriamo che tutto il nostro lavoro per
cui abbiamo investito molto tempo non
era sbagliato
era giusto tornando al ragazzo con il
maglioncino rosso in prima fila il
ragazzo mi stava chiedendo queste il
ragazzo mi stava chiedendo etichette mi
stava chiedendo risposte che qualcuno
aveva sperimentato prima di lui che lui
poteva mettere in tasca e tirare fuori
il giorno del suo colloquio con il
datore di lavoro mi stava dicendo che
non aveva tempo per poter elaborare una
visione scommettere su questa ma
attenzione un giovane che pensa di non
avere tempo e perché probabilmente non è
stato educato ad avere tempo un ragazzo
che dice appunto di non poter investire
quel tempo perché probabilmente è stato
educato a cercare le risposte ma non a
fare le domande un ragazzo che risponde
non lo so quando gli viene chiesto che
cosa vuoi fare nel futuro non è
semplicemente un ragazzo che non ha
fantasia e probabilmente un ragazzo a
cui non è stato insegnato che perdere
fallire fa parte del gioco che deve
rischiare perché è vero che può fallire
ma c'è qualcuno che lo sostiene
nel momento in cui fallirà io penso che
il giorno in cui abbiamo trasformato le
università in esamifici le famiglie in
rifugi isolanti l'arena politica in un
luogo di sterile retorica
quel giorno noi abbiamo cominciato a
costruire le fondamenta per quel futuro
apocalittico che i media
raccontano ai giovani oggi che li rende
così pessimisti ma se veramente vogliamo
dare un senso ad una parola che va tanto
di moda oggi e che riempie la bocca di
tanti che è cambiamento non possiamo far
finta che questo pessimismo non esista e
dobbiamo trovare una via d'uscita è
l'unica via d'uscita è quella di tornare
finalmente a dare delle vere opportunità
ai giovani che vuol dire insegnargli che
la vera ricchezza non sta nel cercare le
risposte ma nel fare le domande
dovremmo insegnarli che dovremo
continuare a dare il valore di
immaginare e lo possiamo fare solo
cercando di dare di nuovo un valore e un
senso ad una parola così maltrattata da
tanto tempo che è cultura
perché un giovane che non ha il coraggio
di scommettere sulle proprie visioni che
ritiene che non valga la pena prendersi
il giusto tempo per avere una visione
scommettere su di essa è un giovane che
non sta compromettendo solo il suo
futuro ma sta compromettendo il futuro
di tutti noi
grazie
[Applauso]